They say there is no US soldier
in Afghanistan.
I'm here and I'll help as long
as it takes I came here to get
my family out I couldn't do
so but I've helped plenty
of other people and it feels
good getting them up saving them
from the Taliban it feels good
but I've gotten out several
minorities Catholics Christians
hijra minorities and other
individuals and upwards of 30
individuals that I've helped it
out to Pakistan when I came
to the US just a few days before
9/11 didn't have anything I
still wore Afghan clothes
and a turban I went to high
school finished high school
and then I came across
a recruiter and I joined the US
Army right now I'm in Pakistan
but I
came about a month ago and I
went to Afghanistan but it's not
the official crossing I came I
got went in and out several
times oftentimes bringing more
people in the game those that
have lives those that have
handlers in Islamabad
or Peshawar waiting for them
they just need help get them
in because of that closed border
I've come across many different
groups here I came across
a family of 10 Afghan Christians
who needed to be moved and we
helped move them
and we're hoping their past that
have already made it out you
guys just went to visit
my family help my mom and dad I
greatly appreciate that,
man I just want to thank you
you're doing a risky job
but still you're the man bro was
a Catholic husband and wife that
needed help to get to Pakistan
and they were in danger
because of their religion they
have converted to Catholicism
recently everyone
in their neighborhood knew about
it and they saw snitching
on them this case reached me I
agreed to help them they crossed
into Pakistan but not
the official crossing
but instead we sought help from
the Afghan nomads and they
illegally crossed them
in on my way back from this area
I got caught by the Taliban
and they lashed me on my back I
told them I was a cigarette
smuggler
and that's why I think it was
only seven times.
But had they known that I had
actually just held a Catholic
family get out it would have
been worse, far worse.
I started feeling chills I spoke
to a medic friend of mine
in the US Army Special forces
medic and he was probably
infected.
So I took some Tylenol and a few
other pills And it got better
we're not proud of the American
soldiers taking a note
and I'll never forget that I
pleaded for help from the US
government I did not receive any
needed help to get my family out
my journalist needs Afghanistan
but it didn't work out I had no
choice but to come here myself
after I learned that there was
an ambush on my family's House
once more I still haven't heard
any anything from our government
as far as any sort of assistance
my family is currently at a safe
House alone by themselves just
the family of six the Taliban
have this thing called the
photo album let's call it they
have photos of high value
individuals that they're looking
for we heard that my niece is
one of those individuals there
was one incident where
the Taliban showed up outside
of the safe House my friends
helped her move my family out
of there and in the process
my niece got injured chest
trauma bruises and her thumb
looked like it got broken
but I'm not sure it's injured
or very bad the injury healed
but the fear from that day is
still there.
My niece is extremely sick
they're afraid we have brought
five different doctors to see
her she's given various types
of injections and medication
but she's not getting better
she's depressed she's afraid
she's in really bad shape right
now.
And on top of that I had this
new place where
they're at outside of Kabul.
They're low on water and food
even the kids have barely
anything to eat at this point
my friends were watching
and protecting their data
or food whatever they can come
up with they're giving it
to my family even Pakistan here
is not safe for my niece she is
anti-taliban she has always
spoken out about how this region
does not stop at the border
they're already in Pakistan.